really good people will say i got lucky
here i had a lucky break here if
somebody tells you how great they are i
think it's probably not somebody you
want to do business with how do you
think about giving away money for most
of my life i was trying to make money
then when i got lucky in business and
started making money you realize you
have more money than you need a lot of
the wealthiest people i know are
tortured souls and the happiest people i
know are often not people that have a
lot of money so you have to be careful
not to let the money uh distort your
views of what it means to be happy talk
a little bit more about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies people have less
confidence in the governments generally
and their currency is being devalued so
they think that cryptocurrencies won't
be devalued and quite that way all
investing is about predicting the future
and what about areas that you're most
excited about well um all right guys
i've got david here with me david i
thought a great place to start is just
being a good decision maker uh you
obviously have navigated a multitude of
different uh opportunities and risks
throughout your career across a number
of different industries when you think
of good decision makers are there
certain qualities that fit into what
makes a good decision maker
sure of course decision making in
politics or in business or investments
is somewhat different but they have some
certain common strands
whenever you make a decision you have
imperfect information
you never know for certain uh what the
outcome is going to be but you also
don't know all the factors that are
going to lead to the outcome it's often
said that presidents united states when
they make decisions have imperfect
information but the truth is everybody
has imperfect information who should you
marry uh
what career should you pursue what
school should you go to you never have
all the perfect information you want so
i think in making decisions you have to
recognize this and then also when you
make the decision try to pursue it and
make certain that you are going to try
to make that decision the good decision
and not look back at all the time that
you probably made a mistake in you know
i i have this tendency to look at
mistakes i've made and realize i should
have done better i think a better
decision maker than me would say let's
move forward and make the decision work
and not look back and say why did you
not invest in amazon or facebook at the
beginning
when you think about decision making
frameworks uh jeff bezos famously has
the kind of regret minimization
framework are there things that you use
uh throughout your career that you feel
like hey this puts me in a better
position or is a way that i think about
decisions that i know are big decisions
well what i try to do is read as much as
possible
and talk to as many people as possible
who have some relevant information but
in the end you have to use what is often
called your gut your intuition which is
really your set of your experiences and
and try to
uh recognize that decision you're about
to make may not be perfect but it
doesn't have to be perfect for it to be
a reasonably good decision most of the
decisions i've made haven't been perfect
but they've worked out reasonably well i
take chances you always have to take
some chances and try to do things that
you know people tell you you probably
can't do
as a general rule of thumb whenever
you're trying to do something new people
will tell you you can't do that and
that's true with entrepreneurs investors
and so forth so i've tried to listen to
people that have good experience but in
the end you have to make the decision
yourself and stick with it
one of the things that's unique that i'm
personally fascinated with is uh there's
a very big difference in uh the amount
of information someone has access to so
if you go back you know 100 years
obviously today we have much more
information than those people had but
even in today's society there's kind of
a bifurcation somebody in your position
or who runs a very large corporation you
have a big team you can say to someone
hey go do research on this gather as
much data as possible give me an
analysis on these three
potential options and then i'll make a
decision but still you mentioned making
decisions using intuition using your gut
and kind of the totality of your
experiences how do you balance when to
use data and when to go with your gut
and is there a way that you've figured
out over the years that works for you
well of course there's an inherent bias
that generally people want to make
certain decisions based on their own
experience and so if you get data that
is inconsistent with your experience or
your intuition you might probably
discount it a bit
if you get information that goes into
accord with your information with your
intuition or gut you probably are going
to accept it uh people generally like to
have information that goes along with
what they already believe in the end um
i think most people make most decisions
based on their intuition and they try to
seek information that might uh be in
accord with it even though realistically
they are probably consciously
not going forward to seek information
that might be against their intuition or
gut
when i think of you i think of someone
who just gathers lots and lots of
information and you do that obviously by
reading a lot but also having tons of
conversations both privately and
publicly let's start with reading is
there certain ways that you read are you
somebody who picks up a book and you're
going to finish it no matter what do you
start reading a book and if you just
don't like it you put it down and pick
up another one do you read one book at a
time do you read multiple books at a
time how do you kind of approach reading
and gathering information
well i have a force-feeding way of doing
it i do a lot of interviews of authors
and so i feel that be appropriately
honest with them i try to read the book
and therefore i try to um know what i'm
talking about when i when i interview
them uh secondly i like to read multiple
books uh at a time because i you know
some book may get
boring at a point point in time and so
you might put it down and pick up
another book and then eventually come
back to the first book i try to finish
the books because i think it's a
courtesy to
to the author but also i think it kind
of shows a certain commitment to getting
things done if you're repeatedly reading
books and it's not finishing them you're
probably doing other things in life
where you're not finishing it and i
think it's generally a good lesson in
life to start something and try to
finish it within reason
that makes a a ton of sense when you
think about reading is it all
non-fiction or do you read fiction as
well or how do you think about the
genres that you read
yeah i i wish i could tell you that i
was a perfect person i read fiction and
non-fiction and i i'm indifferent but
the truth is i am uh a non-fiction
reader i try to juggle three or four
books at a time generally preparing for
interviews or things that might be of
interest to me but there's a trick to it
i'm often reading books on subjects i
know something about so it doesn't take
me that long to get through them if i'm
reading a book on physics or
chemistry i'm probably not going to get
through that book that quickly i'm
reading a book on business politics
history biographies i probably know a
fair bit of it already it can get
through it relatively quickly um
why don't i read fiction i guess i have
a view that i'm not really looking for
great literature and great writing style
as much as trying to get facts and i
generally feel you'll get more facts in
non-fiction than fiction though i
recognize that many fiction books are
heavily researched and they actually
have a fair amount of facts in them but
i generally go for non-fiction and then
you know it's one of my flaws i i don't
really read that many uh fiction books
i i fortunately are unfortunately and
very similar and uh just enjoy the
nonfiction which i think is okay to uh
to just know what you like and uh and go
and double down on that uh you you
obviously talk to a lot of folks as well
whether you're interviewing them for the
shows or or just for your everyday
activities
and one of the ideas that has stuck with
me over the years uh actually was told
to me by my wife and she said the
quality of conversations are driven by
the quality of the questions i thought
that was very kind of illuminating how
do you think about questions to ask and
how do you know that a question is high
quality versus maybe a question that
won't actually elicit a great response
well um i try to prepare for my
interviews as you obviously do and i try
to make sure i know you know generally
what i want to talk about but it's very
important as you know to listen to what
the person is saying when i interviewed
oprah once she said i'm not a great
interviewer she said about herself but
i'm a great listener which meant that
when she hears what somebody's saying
she can pivot and go to what the person
is willing to talk about and seems
interested in talking about so i i do
try to prepare questions in advance when
i'm interviewing people but i always
will be prepared to kind of divert and i
also try to use some humor sometimes and
uh try to make the the experience for
the interviewee uh acceptable and
likable and therefore i don't use a
style where i'm trying to embarrass
people i'm not trying to make them make
a confession they don't otherwise want
to make um they're people that do that
that just isn't what i feel comfortable
doing when you think about these
conversations uh a lot of the
conversations are positioned as
peer-to-peer uh given that you are a
highly successful uh investor and
someone who's built a very large asset
management firm and many of the people
that you are talking with run large
corporations or are well-known investors
how is that um kind of mechanism or that
aspect of the conversation different
than let's say if you were interviewing
people who weren't nearly as successful
or if you yourself wasn't as successful
as the people you were interviewing well
that's a good question and when they
came up with the name peer-to-peer for
the tv show i didn't think it was a good
idea because i didn't want to say i'm a
peer to some of the people i'm
interviewing who are much more
successful and accomplished than me but
i have found by by being um reasonably
successful in business and by having
written books or done other things that
have made me reasonably well known
um when i'm interviewing somebody i
don't feel like i'm a supplicant at the
table basically begging them for morsels
of information they generally i'm
interviewing people that i know
or the people that i that know of me and
i think to some extent respect me and
therefore it's not like i am um you know
begging them for some information i feel
like i'm having a conversation with
somebody that more or less is i'm not a
peer but somebody that i can have a
conversation with and they don't think
they're talking down to me or they're
dealing with somebody that's quote
inferior
you studied a lot of american history
and in these conversations we can go all
the way back uh even further than just
american history to ancient rome all the
way up until modern day and obviously
the conversations in public are an
important part of culture they drive a
lot of how society thinks about certain
ideas what is the role today of some of
these conversations right you are
obviously distributing them on
traditional uh media platforms uh but
also some of the new media platforms as
well how do you think about the role or
importance of these conversations
well it's an interesting phenomenon
there are no interviews of george
washington abraham lincoln other people
from more than 50 or 70 years ago it
just wasn't a technique that was used
and if people were interviewed they
weren't recorded and therefore people
didn't really know what george
washington might think about this or
that
today we have information overload
everybody is an interviewer i feel like
there should be a bumper sticker that
says hunk if you don't have your own
podcast because everybody is doing
interviews of everybody else and so you
kind of wonder who's left to be
interviewed because everybody's
interviewing everybody else um but you
know obviously i'm being facetious but
um i i do think um you know people are
interested in absorbing information the
theory of life to some extent is the
more information you have about
something the better decisions you can
make and the better life you have so
people are interested in learning more
about what people have to say because
they might learn something to make might
make their life better why are so many
people uh listening to podcasts because
they want information because
information is is the key to success if
people who are well informed generally
do better than people are not well
informed in life and as a result people
have observed that and what they want to
do is get more information and now
there's in many ways of doing it in my
case i interview a lot of people i have
an intellectual curiosity you obviously
have that as well and it makes it easier
if you're not interested in learning
what somebody has to say you probably
won't be good at interviewing
it's such a simple but powerful idea of
just those who are informed are likely
to be more successful than those that
are not informed but it's still
important for people to remember that
you've also uh seemed to learn quite a
bit from the stories of people's lives
right there's some people who say hey i
read by going and consuming textbooks
other people read by uh going and
reading some sort of book written about
a topic but i know that even some of the
books that you've written are based on
interviews about people's lives talk a
little bit about why that's so valuable
to you
you know if i thought i was so great i
would say i don't care how anybody else
got to where they are um because i've
done more than they've done but i don't
look at him that way i look at i came
from modest circumstances i like to see
how other people rose up to where they
are and we'll compare it to how i did it
and like people have a willingness as
you know now know to talk about their
childhood their their young adulthood
and they kind of like to tell their
story of how they got where they are and
i think really good people
who have certain amount of humility and
i think good people do have humility
will say i got lucky here i had a lucky
break here if somebody tells you how
great they are in the interview process
and how lucky the world is to have
discovered them i think it's probably
not somebody you want to do business
with or you want to spend that much time
with yeah it makes a lot of sense when
you mentioned that no one interviewed
george washington or we don't have you
know podcasts with many of these
historical figures uh one thing that
i've heard you talk about previously is
that a number of billionaires even just
in recent times were quite reclusive uh
you have the daniel ludwigs and people
who almost were obsessed with privacy
and being out of the limelight obviously
today uh there seems to be a different
uh kind of social scene if you will
people are going on interviews they're
going on podcasts they're tweeting
they're putting out all of this
information what are the pros and cons
of kind of this shift in the way that uh
people are interacting with information
and also with privacy right well there's
an old saying if you live by the sword
you die by the sword and by that
in this context it means if you want all
this uh the world to know about you
presumably you want the world to know
about you because you think you've done
something useful for people to learn
about or you think you've you've done
something people should should emulate
but then when you make a mistake and the
world is still attentive to what you're
saying you don't look as good so people
like good publicity people generally
don't like bad publicity so the downside
to seeking publicity or getting to be
well known is that when something
doesn't go well uh people tend to uh
focus on it there's a german word called
scheiden freud which basically means you
take
uh pride not pride you take um happiness
in other people's failures and so to
some extent we see a lot of that a lot
of people who are very prominent
powerful
when they fall down they make a mistake
people seem to want to read more about
that because it says to them look this
person isn't as great as they thought
they were or i thought they were they
made human mistakes and basically if
they can make a mistake then maybe i can
make a mistake as well
and not feel bad about the fact that i'm
not perfect
when you first started uh with the
interviews or writing the books what was
the goal did you think that this was
something where you it could actually
have a learning process and you were
able to extract information and use it
to uh
uh improve your own life or improve your
own business or was it very much like
hey i want to inform the audience of
this information
most people that start companies there
are not uh so ego centric that they
think they're going to start the next
apple or
microsoft or facebook they start with a
modest ambitions and i had the same
situation in starting my interviewing i
became the president of the economic
club of washington i was supposed to
bring business people in to speak they
were they came in but they were boring
so i thought maybe i could live it up by
interviewing them and people seemed to
like it i used some humor bloomberg
picked it up and now i find that people
like the way i do it for whatever reason
and so i i think it's not something i i
thought would build be part of my life
or career but i i've now find and you
probably have the same experience
although i built a large company i have
with the help of others i chair a lot of
non-profit boards and i've been involved
in a lot of philanthropic things when i
go around the world people come up to me
and they want a selfie because they've
seen my interviews or they've heard my
interviews and many people don't know
that i do anything else many young
people teenagers or young adults they've
seen me on television and they think
this is all i do full time and i you
know i don't want to get an argument
with them that this is not the most
significant thing i do but i am
surprised at how so many people seem to
watch the interviews and so many people
seem to enjoy them
i think a huge piece of it is uh i've
seen your conversations on the airplane
once you've made it onto the airplane
then i think you've got a whole new
demographic right
yes i mean i
i i was surprised that bloomberg takes
the interviews i guess they sell into
some airplanes and i guess if you're on
the airplane you have nothing better to
do you can flip to my channel um you
know i i've been surprised about it but
honestly uh you know i'm very surprised
yeah when you have uh young people
coming up to you and taking selfies and
probably asking questions that have
nothing to do with uh carlisle or any of
the investment activities uh what's your
reaction like is this something that you
uh are still surprised by today do you
just look at it as you're learning from
these people what is that interaction
like
well my reaction is i'm i guess i take
some pride and somebody cares about
me or once i have a picture i never say
no because i you know remember i'm in
the same situation myself for much of my
life trying to get you know get to know
people um and and so i try to be as
polite as possible about it um i am
surprised that they have they have a
view that a picture with me is going to
make their life happier or an autograph
by me is going to make their life
happier but why i don't try to disabuse
them i say sure happy having a picture
and um you know it go from there so um
doesn't upset me i am surprised
sometimes that
that uh you get people that get to be
famous or well well-known and then they
don't want any of the attention that
comes with being a movie star a
television star and you kind of say why
did they go in that business to begin
with because what do they think they
were doing
yeah it is a it's a very interesting and
unique dynamic do you ever feel like uh
being well known although it comes with
lots of benefits the downsides may not
be worth it like are there things that
you've changed in your life because of
it
sure um you you have lots of downsides
um
you know people don't always write 100
uh of what you want or they don't like
how great you are you know we have some
negative articles i've had negative
articles written about me and i realized
if i weren't so prominent in some
respect
people wouldn't have bothered to write
these articles so there is downside to
it and then
um
when my mother was alive um and there
was a negative article about me i had to
go explain it to her that really i'm not
that bad i didn't do what they said and
you know trying to explain something
your mother is always more challenging
but um you know now i have children and
when they see a negative article about
me they kind of say well why did you do
this and i said well it wasn't true i
didn't do that
but you know okay it comes with the
territory
when i told people that i was going to
do this conversation i asked a number of
folks for questions i got some very
unique ones and one of the ones that i
found uh surprising but but also i was
interested in the answer is somebody in
your position do you have like a private
group of peers that you go to for advice
or look for uh to share strategies or
anything that you look at as a way to uh
talk to other folks who are going
through similar situations or is that
something that maybe you would do
earlier in your career but over time
those become less important
no i i have lots of people that i talk
to who help me on various projects in
business or media or or um you know
philanthropy and so i ask their advice
from time to time but in the end you
have to make your own decision so
um recently the new york post wrote a
critical thing about some philanthropic
contribution i made 10 years ago and you
know i i talked to people about it they
didn't think it was that serious not to
worry about it too much but sometimes uh
you know you get good advice from people
that are close to you you have to be
willing to listen to bad at them
listen to the things that you've done
bad and try to correct them uh and
probably people are close to you will
tell you that more than the people who
are not close to you
you've made quite a number of uh
philanthropic contributions and so
obviously somewhere along the line
somebody will have a critical view of
one or many of them how do you think
about giving away money is there a
formula or a framework that you use or
do you just wait until there's
opportunities that you find interesting
and then you make the decision on a
one-off basis um it's the first thing
you have to get over the threshold of
giving away money i i for most of my
life i was trying to make money or can i
you know have enough resources to
to feed the family and all that then
when i got lucky in business and started
making money you realize you have more
money than you need to spend a
reasonable lifestyle you can always
improve your lifestyle or enhance your
lifestyle by buying more homes or art or
something or another but i don't think
that makes people happy
a lot of the wealthiest people i know
are tortured souls and the happiest
people i know are often not people that
have a lot of money so you have to be
careful not to let the money distort
your views of what means
what it means to be happy
in my case once i got over the threshold
of giving away money i'd worked so hard
to make i decided i had four standards
one i wanted to start something
otherwise wouldn't get started
two finish something that wouldn't
otherwise get finished
three do something where i'd have an
intellectual engagement with it so i
wouldn't just write a check and go away
but give my time my energy my ideas as
well as my money and fourth i'd like to
see progress in my lifetime that doesn't
mean i'm going to solve all problems
with my philanthropy but i'd like to see
some progress and not clearly in case
it's difficult to do that last night i
hosted an event for sloan kettering
which the cancer hospital in new york at
one of my homes and
you know i've given money for pancreatic
cancer there and i realized that there's
been progress in pancreatic cancer not
necessarily because of my gift but that
i'm not going to solve pancreatic cancer
probably in my lifetime still i want to
see some progress being made and
progress has been made
how do you check in so if you give money
and you're saying hey i want to see
progress or i want to see something that
would get finished that otherwise
wouldn't get finished are these folks
giving you
monthly reports are you kind of checking
in do you have a team how does that work
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod three you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to
pomp aidsleep.com to go ahead and get
150 off your order
aidsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company 8sleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
i'm probably not as good at that as i
should be i don't have a team i do it
all myself i kind of know what i want to
do and 95 of my philanthropic things are
my ideas so like most people i like my
ideas better than somebody else's ideas
when people present me with ideas i
sometimes do them and sometimes i don't
but i i don't have a big team going
around looking at metrics bill gates is
much more sophisticated than i am he's
got elaborate metrics that measure you
know the success of the money he's given
away i generally uh if it's a medical
research thing i'll read some things
from time to time you do get reports
from people but the reports that you get
generally going to tell you how great
your money has been and so i usually uh
in solving a problem or something so i
usually try to just make my own
observations i might if it's a building
that i helped to build or something i
would try to visit it or ask other
people who visited the building what
they think about it but in the end once
you've given the money it's kind of gone
and you have to decide whether you want
to give more for the same cause or not
and very rarely the people you give
money to say well we solve the problem
and we don't need any more money so
you're usually going to get more money
money requests from the same people
you've already given money to this may
seem like an elementary question but i
used to ask uh folks you know what did
you do when you first realized you were
a billionaire but in this case what
would be fascinating i think for folks
to hear is the very first building that
you gave money to and after it was built
and you went and saw it what did you do
did you look at it and say looks like a
nice building like let's go to lunch or
did you walk through it like how did
that go when you realized that i made a
financial contribution to build the very
first building
the first building that i really built
was my alma mater duke university came
to me and this is before i was on the
board or later became chairman of the
board but i and and so my parents were
alive and i uh they asked me for uh
money to help build a building and i
said okay and we had a ceremony colin
powell came down and spoke and so forth
and i told my mother that they named the
building after me and my mother had
never seen something like that uh you
know a building named after her son when
we went down for the ceremony um my name
wasn't anywhere and my mother kept
looking and she said well your name's on
the building i don't see it anywhere i
said well you know maybe they don't put
the sign up and actually it was a place
where they did that duke they didn't
really put your names on the building so
much but i i don't know whether my
mother ever believed that building was
named after me but recently i talked
about this and the dean of the school
then put my name in the building
recently they felt bad that uh that your
mom didn't really believe you so they
hooked you up i don't think she really
believed my my name was on the building
but anyway
that's amazing uh as you built carlisle
uh that story has been uh i think pretty
well documented but one of the things
that is interesting a lot of folks
listening to this come from the asset
management world uh and they usually
start off with one single asset class
how did you all that carlisle think
about okay we're gonna start with the
single asset class and then we're gonna
move to something that encompasses many
more industries and many more uh
investment disciplines what was kind of
the impetus for that and how did you
think about where to expand with the
second third and fourth asset class
um
whenever you come up with a new idea you
kind of do it uh
gingerly for a while and then that
people tell you it's not a good idea so
i didn't want to broadcast guess what
we're in the buyout business but now
we're going to get into growth capital
venture capital real estate i just had
an idea that like fidelity or t rowe
price or or vanguard we could have many
different funds taking advantage of our
brand name and ultimately people thought
we were good in area a they might give
us a chance in area b or then area c and
so forth so i i just came up with this
idea of having multiple funds and i told
my partners i will go
uh
determine the area recruit people help
raise the money and then they would
oversee the investments and at the time
it didn't seem like it was uh you know
the
discovering uh a fire or anything like
that but it's something that's obviously
taken off and now firms like blackstone
kkr apollo and among others have
multiple asset classes and then i
decided while i was doing this that
would globalize it by going around the
world and building arms in europe asia
and so forth and at the time it didn't
seem like a brilliant idea but it turned
out it changed uh private equity a bit
when you thought about moving into those
other asset classes what were the
conversations with investors like did
they just say hey we're willing to bet
on you and your firm or did you have to
convince them that you actually had some
expertise or some unique opportunity set
uh to go after in the new asset classes
well uh sometimes the areas are very hot
so for example um i made a speech in
london in the in the late 90s saying
that there was no internet related fund
in europe and that carl i was going to
build one we didn't have any team yet we
really didn't know exactly what we would
do but we were inundated with requesting
funded and so i realized there i had hit
and interest level but generally what i
did is at the beginning i would say to
people we we've made a lot of money for
you in buyouts in the us give us a
chance in buyouts in europe we have a
same kind of process and approach and
some people say no some people say yes
uh and in the fundraising world as you
may know you don't get 100 of the people
you ask money for uh for to give you the
money so you know you have to be
comfortable with a very low percentage
of people going to give you money
certainly for a first fund
it would be beautiful if 100 of the
people you asked said yes that would
change a lot of people's lives uh when
you think about uh your business many
people from the outside would label you
as an investor they say oh that's the
business that he's in uh but you're also
an entrepreneur you had to build
carlisle and obviously scale it was
there any key ideas on how to actually
scale the business or anything that you
took away from the entrepreneurship side
of building an investment firm
well the the two entrepreneurial ideas
other than starting the company in
washington dc which was somewhat seen as
unusual place to start an investment
firm was to have multiple disciplines
many different kinds of investments and
then to globalize it by having funds
around the world and those were
entrepreneurial ideas i had to convince
my partners of and also investors and
and and recruiting people i had to
convince them that we would pay
attention to their fund even though it
wasn't our core fund it takes time and
obviously success breeds more success so
those early funds that were global
tended to work out and we could build on
there and obviously other firms have
probably done it as well as we have or
better in some cases so it wasn't easy
in the beginning but if you go back and
look at entrepreneurship uh you'll see
that most entrepreneurs um have ideas
that people make fun of for a while and
then they they stumble along and they
make some mistakes and ultimately the
idea takes off that's the case in like
to amazon or facebook or or apple or
microsoft
when we think about kind of the world
you're a unique person to talk about
what's transpiring in the modern day
you're a student of history you've got a
global investment firm you've talked to
people both entrepreneurs and investors
that are incredibly successful from
various parts of the world
there are other investors like ray dalio
who've recently come out with books
talking about the changing world order
and kind of the shifting ground
underneath us how do you evaluate what's
going on and what do you pay attention
to and what do you think maybe is just
noise in the news or some of the recent
events
well you can't read too much about
what's going on around the world because
anything going on around the world the
news is likely to affect investments
because investments are just a a
microcosm of what's going on in you know
in larger society um so ray dalio i've
interviewed him about his books and
they're really well written and well
researched and he's obviously a very
thoughtful person and i would say that
um you know i i've learned a lot from
interviewing i mean i try to learn a lot
when i interview people
i don't know the answers to every
question that i ask somebody and so i do
learn a lot i read a lot before i do the
interview but i learn a lot more during
the interview than before the interview
when you think about uh this idea of
kind of the the shifting world and these
debt cycles and all of that is that
something that you ascribe to and you
all talk about internally at carlisle uh
or is it something that you know it's an
interesting theory but maybe we need
more information to know how accurate
they actually are well we do internally
uh get information about what the
government's doing or what the federal
reserve is doing but i don't think our
information is any better than anybody
else's information we you know we we
read the same things we talk the same
experts but in the end you have to
figure out what you can do with that
information how you can take advantage
of it in an appropriate way to kind of
make a good investment decision and
remember most investment decisions are
going to have some mistakes with them
and you have to learn how to deal with
the mistakes when you make them
yeah and when you start to evaluate
let's say the inside of the united
states obviously you started out earlier
in your career actually working inside
of one of the administrations and now
you're
one of the leading investors how do you
think about the us's rise uh and all of
the economic growth that we've
experienced and then now it seems to be
you know kind of at a fork in the road
if you will will it continue or will
there be some uh kind of you know maybe
not demise of the empire but definitely
some uh um retraction in that growth
well no um civilization or a country has
ever been the dominant one forever
you know civilizations uh become leaders
and then the ultimately their time comes
and goes so we all know about ancient
egypt greece rome and so forth and then
in our you know uh last couple hundred
years england was the dominant uh
financial and economic and military
power in the world uh for for much of
the uh 19th century united states came
along and became the biggest economy in
the world in the 20th century the
leading military technological economic
educational tech uh country in the world
how long will that continue well nobody
really knows we have a disadvantage now
and that our population is not as large
as china's and as long as china is
trying to to do the kind of things we do
they they have an advantage over
population now we have other advantages
as well uh that they don't have but i
don't know i can't tell you that for
another 100 or 200 years the united
states is going to be as dominant as we
were during the 20th century that seems
unlikely
when you think about demographics
there's plenty of investors who say hey
just follow the demographics and that's
where opportunity lies how important are
those demographics to your investing
philosophy or a lot of the work that you
do
well demographics are obviously
important because you know you need to
have a reasonably good size population
to sell products or services and then
you want to have a reasonably young
population that is going to buy some of
these things because younger people tend
to buy more than maybe older people do
so of course demographics are very
important and i think really good
investors take advantage of that and
know what the democratic democrat
demographic impact is of
of what's going on in society because
that can shape how you make investment
decisions
when we think about demographics that's
obviously something that's much more of
a macro trend it's not something that
uri could wave a magic wand and change
especially in the short term uh but what
does seem to be uh kind of uh opposite
of demographics uh is central banks and
central banks can much more have an
impact in the short term they can wave
magic wands and change the cost of
capital or change quantitative easing
quantitative tightening how do you think
about the roles of central banks and
especially in environments where they
seem to be making many more short-term
decisions is that something that you all
are actively trying to make investment
decisions around or is it something that
you're aware of but it doesn't
necessarily drive the investment
decisions
well i would say it has an impact um you
know i j pal was in our firm for seven
or eight years he left and then got
involved in some public policy things
and then got appointed the fed later
chairman of the fed by president trump
um we're no different than anybody else
we don't have any particular insights
that about what jay pal is going to do
we know you know to get the same
information everybody else does but we
there's no doubt that the federal
reserve and the central banks play a
much larger role in the global economy
than they did 50 years ago or 100 years
ago because now everybody knows exactly
what they're doing and pretty much why
they're doing it and many central banks
around the world are so coordinated with
the federal reserve that they're likely
to follow what the federal reserve is
doing so it's a much bigger impact than
it was let's say 50 years ago in our
country how much of the impact is driven
by the actual policy decisions they're
making like they're just making certain
policy decisions that have the impact
versus it's more about the way that they
communicate i recently heard somebody
talking about the fact that you know the
fed used to not really do press
conferences they used to not really go
out and say what they were going to do
now it seems like that's a huge part of
their policy uh kind of decision making
process is they try to actually signal
to the market what to think how has that
played a role in the kind of economic
growth or economic uh strength of the
united states
well uh secrecy used to be the coin of
the realm for the federal reserve it was
not unlike the supreme court uh we'll
tell you what our decision is at some
point but or you can figure it out but
basically what the federal reserve
didn't do before was tell you what they
were going to do in advance and they
didn't explain it after they did it uh
when paul volcker was the chairman of
the fed they would just one weekend
increase interest rates uh the federal
discount rate by 200 basis points they
didn't explain in advance or didn't
explain afterwards you had to figure it
out today everybody believes that
transparency is a greater
virtue than than secrecy and therefore
the fed telegraphs exactly what it's
going to do and then after it does it it
explains it in great detail that's much
different than it was 50 years 100 years
ago and it does give you information
that can guide what you're going to do
in your investment process
do you think that it's a positive on the
market or do you think that actually it
was better off when uh people were
forced to do the work themselves and
figure it out
when you had to do the work yourself
only a limited number of people probably
had the expertise to figure it out and
therefore it was an advantage to those
limited number of
firms or people that had you know
expertise in that area today the theory
is everybody should have equal
information and therefore everybody will
have equal opportunity to benefit or not
benefit from what the federal reserve is
doing on the whole it's hard to be
against transparency so i i i think it's
a good thing um and i i support what
they're doing i think
jay powell has done one other thing in
addition to
explaining and telegraphing what he's
doing he tries to do it in the king's
english in other words uh many for
chairman of the fed used to speak in
what's called fed speed which is almost
incomprehensible to the average person
so you didn't really know in many cases
what alan greenspan was actually trying
to say to you because he talked into
kind of what's called fed speak um now
jay pal um tried to speak in english and
therefore it's much more easily
understood by the average person
yeah one of the things that fascinates
me about central banks in general but
the federal reserve obviously is the one
i think most people in america will pay
the most attention to
is they are making decisions based on
data and as i've learned more and more
about the data sets they use and the
data collection methodology it feels
like there is uh kind of the way that
we've always done things obviously with
the bureau of labor statistics and a lot
of that data collection but now we have
companies like square or zillow who have
real-time data points and usually much
more expansive than maybe the data sets
that the fed is looking at how do you
think about using kind of the old
methodology versus some of these new
tech companies and is there a world
where you think will eventually
transition to the new uh kind of
technology data points or do you
actually think that maybe there's
downsides to using that real-time data
versus the systems we've been using
over the years i've interviewed ben
bernanke janet yellen
uh jay pal and i asked that question i
say it seems like you're gathering
information sometimes the same way you
did 20 or 30 years ago you know you ask
people to fill out forms or so forth and
and maybe their people are going to fill
them out accurately or not i do wonder
at times whether the information
gathering process of the federal
government is as good as it is in the
private sector i tend to get the answer
from the federal reserve that they have
very good computers and despite what i
might think that they really have good
access to information i'll take their
word for it but i
clearly uh of a business person were to
go in and run the federal reserve i
suspect
people today who are business people
would probably use different techniques
than the fed is traditionally used to
gather information um you know and and
for example some of the statistics not
the fed but other parts of the federal
government gather information in ways
that what seems somewhat archaic or they
use statistics that seems somewhat
archaic for example the unemployment
rate which is a much watched statistic
is basically dealing with the percentage
of the workforce um that are looking for
jobs so if the workforce shrinks uh you
can still have a very low unemployment
rate because there's fewer people
looking for work and the unemployment
rate just measures how many people were
looking for work uh last year out of the
people or last month out of the
percentage of the workforce that we're
actively looking as opposed to it
doesn't take into account the people
that gave up looking and so more
accurate numbers probably the percentage
of people in the workforce of a certain
population otherwise right now probably
63 to 64
of the adult population is probably in
the employment market whereas it used to
be higher than that maybe 67 68
yeah it's it's it's a pretty insane when
you start to think about all these
little individual ones but to your point
uh we also are evaluating the accuracy
of the data without actually having
access to the systems and the data sets
themselves and so uh it's a little bit
of a nuanced situation one of the areas
that i think people are fascinated with
uh coming out of the last two and a half
years of the pandemic and many of the
supply chain disruptions uh is this idea
of reshoring so reshoring manufacturing
re-shoring supply chains i know that you
all have both on the private equity side
and the venture capital side gone around
the world you're very familiar with kind
of these international markets how do
you see this playing out is it something
where the united states actually can
bring back manufacturing and supply
chains and are going to be able to do
this with american labor or is it
something that maybe there's theories
that yes we can do it but it's gonna
have to be driven by robotics because
american labor is too expensive compared
to international labor just talk me
through like what you're seeing on this
front well obviously the supply chain uh
for manufactured products largely moved
out of the united states decades ago and
it did that for economic reasons it was
cheaper to produce things overseas
ship in the united states and you could
still sell them for less in walmart than
you could if you produced the same
product united states
when cobit came along we began to
realize that we were so dependent on
let's say china for healthcare products
that it made people nervous and so
there's been pressure from the federal
government on businesses to res uh
re-engineer their supply chains and
you're seeing a lot of that people in
who have manufactured products in china
many of the people now are trying to get
supply supplies coming from non uh
maybe other asian countries but not
necessarily china for which we have some
obviously uh geopolitical tensions at
times um i think the major businesses in
the united states are trying very hard
to re-engineer their supply chain so
they're not dependent on foreign
countries as much particularly china
it's not that easy to do and one of the
problems with that and the reason we
people went to this original system is
that it's inflationary to bring things
back in the united states or potentially
inflationary we produce things the
united states had probably somewhat
higher cost than they do in china even
with the shipping involved so it's going
to take a sustained effort by the u.s
government to push people to change
their supply chains because in the end
you're worried about inflationary
pressures if you push people to come
back here and and and try to produce
things the same cost they're going to do
it in china that's not realistic at this
point what's unique is that uh you
obviously started building carlisle
right there in washington dc uh you have
that experience inside of the
administration uh but you are a
capitalist and an entrepreneur and an
investor how do you think about the role
of the government in something like that
like how much do you say hey the private
sector is going gonna have to pick up
the ball and run with this here versus
no maybe the public sector can actually
help support either through legislation
incentives uh or just outright uh kind
of effort to actually go ahead and have
this happen
when ronald reagan famously said the
most dangerous words in the english
language are i'm here from the federal
government i'm here to help you
um you know and this point was that the
federal government tries to do things to
help people but sometimes it doesn't
really work and and obviously
bureaucracies are what they are by being
based in washington i do know a lot of
government officials and i deal with
them right regularly in terms of
interviews or other things like that it
does give me a sense of what the
government is trying to do from time to
time but in the end given the fact that
so many people can get so much
information so easily these days if you
live in california you can probably get
almost the same information i'm getting
by living in washington
when you think of other asset classes
are there other areas that you're
excited about right now i know that
carlisle has this internal report that's
heavily data driven i had a number of
investors ask me uh specifically hey
what is the data saying now that are the
interesting areas of opportunity um you
know what what are kind of the things
you're most excited about in the moment
what you might be referring to is that
over a number of years we we at carlisle
have taken the data that we get on sales
or earnings or margins or whatever from
our companies and extrapolate that to
how the gdp or the global economy is
performing and then after many years of
doing this we can figure out that if one
of our companies in given area a is
seeing sales decline by five percent it
might have a uh it might show you that
in fact the gdp is going down by x
percent or something like that so we are
looking at that but again you have to
use your intuition your gut you can't
rely only on data the data might not be
perfect in the way it was
accumulated and so forth so i i i don't
want to say that we have an undue
advantage but there's probably some
advantage that other firms can do as
well of taking a look at their own
portfolio and figuring out how what is
going on in their own portfolio tells
you what's likely to be going on in the
economy generally
and what about areas that you're most
excited about
well um
i say areas that i think are going to be
very important for in the future are
ones that and remember um as i say in my
book
all investing is about predicting the
future that's really what life is all
about that's what investing is about
predicting the future in the future
clearly healthcare is going to be a
major continuing uh growth area when i
worked in the white house in the late
1970s the gdp percentage of uh that went
into healthcare was roughly 78
today it's 21 or 22
and that's in part because people have
higher expectations of what they should
get from the healthcare system and also
the population is aging and aging
population generally needs more health
care so it's it's changed a bit i think
therefore number one healthcare and
healthcare services telemedicine all
kinds of other uh things related to
healthcare needs secondly fintech
clearly there's a revolution going on
and we're probably just
ending one or two of changing uh the
world of financial services from the
kind of traditional banks and investment
firms to things that are more fintech
oriented including blockchain and
cryptocurrency related assets so i think
that we'll be likely to see something
i'll be attractive
talk a little bit as well talk a little
bit more about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and kind of what you
see there what are you excited about
what do you think maybe is over hyped or
or uh maybe not as sustainable as people
think
i used to say that if you would go to
las vegas and you um like gambling there
it gives you a form of happiness and
pleasure
knowing that you're going to lose the
money in the end if you stay there long
enough because the odds are always in
favor of the house go ahead and do it
but don't lose more money than you can
afford to lose so put one or two or
three percent in if it gives you
pleasure fine and i used to say the same
about uh cryptocurrencies if you want to
speculate you want to read about all the
things going on there you like the the
thrill of of of crypto currencies okay
put one or two or three percent in today
uh clearly what i think is going on is
that more and more people are doing more
than one or two or three percent and
that reason is that people have less
confidence in the in governments
generally and their currency is being
devalued so they think that
cryptocurrencies won't be devalued quite
that way there's a lot of thrill in the
secrecy of it a lot of thrill that
nobody knows what you actually own
a lot of russian oligarchs saw their
assets being taken away by western
governments and many other wealthy
people around the world are probably
saying well i want to have some assets
that nobody can confiscate nobody knows
that i have and that's what
cryptocurrencies do uh cryptocurrencies
also have a lot of political appeal in
the i would say uh young part of the
society and the libertarian part
probably more republican than democratic
in some respects and they have made
their views known on capitol hill and
therefore i think it's very unlikely
that that capitol hill will find the
political pressure to regulate
cryptocurrencies in ways that some
academics would like or some regulators
would like i just don't see the pressure
coming from capitol hill to do that in
part because of the constituency that is
really involved in cryptocurrencies
what's really interesting is uh there is
a technology aspect there is this like
geopolitical aspect there is a
regulation aspect and then there's a
politics aspect and to me one of the
most interesting uh developments uh have
been in the political realm so obviously
we have countries like el salvador uh
who at least are verbally saying hey we
are going to embrace this people will
debate you know how successful have they
been
in actually going ahead and adopting the
various technologies but even in the
united states we have seen senators and
congressmen come out and say hey i own
these assets or advocate for kind of
positive legislation of it in your
experience having been around for a
while now and seeing multiple asset
classes whether they were things like
etfs or other types of vehicles or just
new asset classes in general
what is usually the takeaways that
people should be looking for from when
the politicians get involved is it just
they provide air cover and it allows
something to get built or the other
takeaways that you have from your career
this episode is brought to you by ledger
the best crypto hardware wallet
everyone's heard the phrase not your
keys not your coins and that's more true
today than it's ever been
ultimately a value proposition of
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies is
self-custody where you get to retain
ownership over your digital assets that
is what ledger specializes in they've
got multiple pieces of hardware and they
also have the ledger live mobile app
which makes it seamless to not only
retain control over your bitcoin but
also allows you to interface with
exchanges lending platforms and other
types of software products if you're
interested in upping your self-custody
game go check out ledger today
shop.ledger.com again that's
shop.ledger.com go check them out and
start doing self custody you'll thank me
later
well remember um when you're trying to
sell a product um a new product what are
the words that madison avenue finds are
the most helpful they're two one is new
and the second is free so we're gonna
give you something for free and it's
gonna be new people love things that are
new and so to some extent that's part of
the appeal of crypto it's new it's
different and younger people tend to
like newer things older people people my
age and older they tend to say well i
know what i know
from my life experiences i don't want to
try something new because i don't fully
understand it so the people pushing
crypto currencies and and related things
are not generally people in their 70s or
80s they're probably people in their 20s
or 30s i interviewed for my tv show the
other day sam bankman freed who you
probably know of he's a 30 year old who
i think had at one point a fortune of
about 20 some billion dollars it's maybe
down a little bit now he built ftx which
is a leading cryptocurrency um exchange
vehicle and um you know he's probably
typical of many of the people in that
generation who are younger they're
willing to try things they they can
afford to
fail and then pick themselves up because
they're so young again and start life
all over again he hasn't failed but i i
i think young people are the ones who
lead revolutions young people are the
ones who pursue things like uh uh you
know the current take take smartphones
or take um uh uh personal computers it
was young people that kind of pushed
that for social media young people that
kind of push that you rarely see
revolutionary companies being started by
people in their 70s or 80s
when you interview somebody like sam
bankman freed who will put them in the
category of young billionaire successful
with new technology uh you also have
interviewed people who were exactly like
him just later in their career and so
whether that's the jeff bezos's or the
bill gates or whoever they are and i
always say that you know uh if the young
challenger lives long enough they become
the incumbent right in some ways bill
gates was trying to take on the
incumbents and now he has become the
incumbent what are the similarities and
differences that you see in some of the
young people today versus
what you're seeing in the successful
billionaires who now are in their 40s
50s and 60s
well in my generation uh younger people
were not as focused on
making fortunes uh and there was no
there were no private equity firms when
i graduated from college there was no or
virtually none
there were no hedge funds or virtually
none and now more and more people in my
generation uh where they were called in
public service by president kennedy and
his famous inaugural address and things
like that people wanted to change the
war in vietnam or things like that now
people when they go to college when they
want to do or if they even want to stay
and graduate they want to go out and
start a business they don't want to go
change the world necessarily they want
to start a business make some money you
know i think the ideal for a lot of
people is to become a billionaire when
you're 30 and then do whatever you want
with the rest of your life it's not that
easy to do but i i do think that more
and more younger people are attracted to
business and entrepreneurial activities
than than was the case 20 or 30 or 40
years ago
you wrote a book the american experiment
and in it you talk about a number of
topics around the american dream and one
of the things you're highlighting here
is this idea of young people still being
highly ambitious wanting to create
wealth wanting to do that within a
country that has democratic principles
and has a capitalistic society how do
you evaluate the current state of the
american dream is it still kind of as
shiny and impossible as it once was do
you think it's improved or maybe it's
been in decline
the irony is that the american dream
that's a phrase that was invented in
1936 to kind of describe what happens
when
very often um
immigrants but not always immigrants
rise up and they they kind of overcome
modest circumstances and hardships and
they become wealthy or successful or
famous
and as a result of that they kind of
live their dream you don't hear the
french dream the mongolian dream the
english dream though obviously some
people in those societies rise up as
well but it's part of our ethos and this
was perpetuated to some extent by the
horatio algeria series of books that
kind of talked about young people coming
from modest circumstances and working
their way up
sadly
sadly the american dream is today a
dream that more people outside of the
united states actually um believe in
than people in the united states uh we
have now 50 million immigrants in this
country many people came here because
they believe the american dream many
people at the bottom of our society born
here no longer think because of
discrimination or prejudice or whatever
reason that they can ever become a part
of it at the top of the potent poll and
can actually live to see the american
dream but the american dream lives on to
some extent in the ideas and minds of
many people who are immigrating into
this country as opposed to people who
are born here
what's fascinating about what you're
saying is the internet i think in many
ways helped to export a lot of these
ethos to other places in the world i
recently had someone on that i was
talking with uh about the country of
india and one of the conclusions uh that
we both came to was look there's now a
kid in india with a keyboard and an
internet connection that can go ahead
and create a business can create a
product can go ahead and achieve that
social mobility and economic success uh
in a place where maybe that wasn't as
easy to do 10 20 30 40 years ago and so
it does feel like there's this
exportation of uh of the american dream
but i do wonder does that mean that
people now
don't need to necessarily come to the
united states and that's like a headwind
for the u.s or do you still see across
the board lots and lots of people
wanting to come to the us to go ahead
and build businesses and kind of achieve
that dream the united states has always
valued entrepreneurial activity and i
think people feel they come here to have
a better chance of creating an
entrepreneurial venture that succeeds
people don't raise their children in
france or germany and say i hope you'll
grow up to be a billionaire it's not
part of the culture as much or in
england now it's changed a little bit
but it's not been historically part of
the culture
now in concurrently i think it's
something like a third of the companies
run from silicon valley or running
silicon valley
are being run by people or immigrants
from india india is a country that
exports a lot of
very talented people in the united
states and uh they are very
entrepreneurial and they built a lot of
very impressive companies uh you have 50
million immigrants in this country the
five countries from which they most come
are number one mexico number two the
philippines number three india number
four china and number five vietnam
that's where the immigrants have largely
come from but india is still increasing
its percentage of people coming in the
united states
when you talk about other cultures uh
not necessarily saying hey i want my kid
to grow up to be a billionaire one thing
that we have seen here in the united
states whether people came from
elsewhere or they were born here in the
u.s is there's been a rise of
billionaires who don't necessarily start
off as business people or as investors
and so a number of people who jump to
mine immediately are people like jay-z
or kanye west and musicians we've also
seen athletes like lebron james uh and
many other examples of this how do you
think about this kind of new type of
business person where they may be an
athlete a musician a celebrity uh or
just famous from reality television and
now getting into business and building
these kind of large organizations that
end up minting them quite a bit of
economic success
one of the reasons is that it's a global
economy in this sense if you are lebron
james
your image is known not only in the
united states but all over the world so
people are going to buy your t-shirts or
whatever you might have your jerseys all
over the world and you become a media
figure all over the world so
more and more people
are
building businesses or building images
that are global so if you are a business
person in the united states you now
really see the whole world as your
market and that's certainly true as well
of athletes or of people that start the
music companies they are known all over
the world because to some extent america
has exported its culture as much as
anything else
when you think about uh kind of the
business world we usually now think of
private equity firms we think of venture
capital funded startups it seems like a
lot of folks especially young people
went from hey i want to work on wall
street at a hedge fund to now i want to
start a tech company or be a venture
capitalist but i noticed that
declaration capital uh which is another
firm that you started uh i believe it
actually serves maybe it's your family
office right uh goes ahead and actually
acquires family-owned businesses and
that seems to be something that was very
popular you know decades ago today we
don't see as many of those getting
started and run talk a little bit about
that sector of the economy and these
family-owned businesses uh that maybe
have kind of getting lost in the story
of entrepreneurship in america
well many companies are owned by
families probably more companies are
owned by families and are publicly
traded for sure and sometimes
family-owned businesses feel they have a
certain culture
which could be destroyed by going public
or by being bought by a quote private
equity firm they feel more comfortable
if they're bought by a family owned
office or operation because those the
values might be the same whether that's
true or not you know we can debate but
there's no doubt that um i have um
through my family office declaration
bought things or affiliated with people
that have family businesses because very
often there's a simpatico feeling that
you know one family office has got the
same kind of values as another family
office
when you think of that family office
that you're running talk a little bit
just in terms of how you thought about
structuring it and you also there are
investing across asset classes and what
i think will be interesting for a lot of
folks in the audience uh there are
people who have been quite successful
and the ones who are younger are just
now hitting the point where they're
starting to think about hey should i
start a family office right what was
that decision uh process like and then
also if i do start a family office and
try to in some ways professionalize it
how should i think about actually uh
where to invest and how to run that
process okay well when i was doing
carlisle full-time i didn't have a
family office and then people kept
saying do you have a family office and
eventually i felt like i had family
office envy i didn't have one so i
eventually i when i stepped down as a
co-ceo carla i decided to build a family
office but family office is an
interesting phenomenon if i tell you i'm
from private equity your eyes might roll
because private equity's images and so
wonderful if i tell you i'm from a
family office people generally think
that's good because the word family
office is a phrase that has no
negative connotations and family office
can mean whatever you want it can be
somebody that's managing five million
dollars it could be some it could be an
operation that pays the bills takes care
of trust in the states deals with
intergenerational issues or it can be
just an investment operation in my own
case declaration is an investment
operation doing things that doesn't that
don't compete with carlisle all the
deals have to be approved by carlos to
make sure there's no no conflict what
i've tried to do is to build an
organization that will survive me
so it's not a typical family office in
the sense that it's mine and then it
goes to my children and their children
it's basically something where i've
recruited i think very good people and
we will we are raising some outside
capital because i want the business to
survive uh well after i'm gone and it
will do so if it's not dependent solely
on my money initially i put up all the
money but now we have some third-party
money increasingly more of it
when you think about hiring those uh
high-quality people what are some of the
lessons you've learned over time uh if
you're going through an interview with
somebody are there certain types of
questions you ask or certain uh specific
characteristics that you're looking in
for people especially early in the
interview process
well when i'm interviewing people i want
to see what makes them tick where they
come from what kind of
background they have how hungry are they
why do they want to make money why don't
they go into public policy why do they
want to make uh money and what do they
want to do with it they want to spend it
they buy a lot of houses or they want to
give it away try to get a sense of what
is important to them and then i try to
see what questions they ask i am amazed
sometimes when i interview young people
they i say you have any questions they
have no questions you know if you have
no questions that's not good always
think of some questions the one question
you should not ask is what's the
compensation because that's really not
something you should focus on uh
eventually you know you'll get you know
be taken care of i have a lot of
experience in hiring people i've made
some mistakes i've hired some people i
shouldn't have and i didn't hire people
i should have hired and i let some
really talented people get away but in
the end that's that's life you make
mistakes how did you know that you had
hired the wrong person like in any of
those situations were there certain
things that happened or or certain
frameworks that you've developed over
time that to know hey we hired this
person they're actually not the right
person we need to move on
you want people that i think know how to
get along with other people investing is
to some extent the way private equity is
undertaken it's a team sport and uh you
have to get people that get along with
other people and if you get people that
don't get along with other people that's
probably not a great thing if people are
not willing to work very hard that's
probably not a great thing if people
don't have certain basic skills in terms
of intellectual curiosity reading uh
certain uh skills in terms of uh math
related kind of projects or things that
we need have to do some kind of
you know discounted cash flows and so
forth i i think you know you may have
made the mistake but i
i you know i've made mistakes and i'm
sure i'm going to make more hiring
mistakes in the future but generally i
try to weed them out relatively early
it's not a good thing to let people uh
stay in an organization where they
clearly are not going to thrive and just
let them stay there and be in the corner
you should let be honest with them and
let them know it's not working out they
should do something different
when you think of your network uh i'm
assuming that references is a huge piece
of it you know a lot of people in a lot
of different areas and you're able to
get some back channel information are
there specific things that you look for
and when you're doing reference checks
in the hiring process
yeah when i'm doing reference checks i
want to know whether
why somebody left the previous place um
and people are very good at uh hiding
whether somebody was actually fired or
not then there's a lot of obfuscation
whether somebody was actually pushed out
or or they quit on their own so you
always want to know if they were fired
why uh those are unique circumstances uh
secondly how do other people work with
this person um people sometimes don't
really wanna be that honest when you're
doing those kind of reference checks uh
third you know what kind of um
academic achievements do they have were
they reasonably good in school are they
terrible in school not that that means
you know
that's the only thing you should look at
but generally i like to talk to people
who have some sense of what they want to
accomplish with their life even if
they're young and they they obviously
are going to say the same things they
want to make the world a better place
and all that but how sincere are they
what type of intellectual curiosity they
have what motivates them are they trying
to please their parents are they trying
to please themselves what are they what
do they really want out of life and you
can get that out of an interview but not
perfectly so
when you look at the motivations it's a
fascinating thing to kind of think
through right so somebody comes in and
you realize the motivation is that they
want to get rich or their motivation is
that they want to impress themselves and
prove that they can do something or our
motivation is their parent how do you
evaluate is there like a right answer
there uh or is it just you're trying to
understand this person better to realize
how they'll fit into the organization
like when you get a variety of answers
to something like motivation how do you
kind of think through what's good or
what's not good for the organization
well austin you're always trying to get
people that are going to get along with
the kind of culture you have you don't
want people to destroy your culture you
want people to improve your culture or
enhance it and you're also looking for
people that i think are honest in what
they're talking about and you can tell
whether they have scripted their answers
because they know that's what your they
want you to they think you want to hear
or whether they really are sincere you
have to ask people questions that they
aren't likely to anticipate because
everybody's going to know the answers to
questions like what do you want to do
with your life or or you know what was
your background like finding people who
um
are being willing to be honest is very
useful and people that are willing to uh
you know go off script and tell you
things that they didn't think they were
going to tell you will tell you a lot
about the kind of person
yeah
my understanding is uh if we go towards
kind of your motivations your life um
one of the things is you've never had
alcohol before and i'm an individual who
uh i would put myself in the average
alcohol consumer until about two years
ago uh and i stopped drinking alcohol uh
not because of some master plan but just
started with a dry january and then i
said hey let's keep the momentum going i
feel great and you know like not waking
up with a hangover and all the the
benefits of not drinking but why is it
that you never even started or you never
even tried alcohol before well i was
when i was a young boy i was in a youth
group in baltimore and the head of the
group was really anti-alcohol and he
kind of said he would get you in trouble
and i didn't want to be getting in
trouble and secondly uh
i would see uh new year's eve adults um
gather and they tended to get drunk
and i saw when people were drunk they
tended to uh you know do things that
they maybe would be embarrassed about
later so i generally didn't want to do
something that was going to embarrass
myself or my parents and i generally
just thought that the benefits of
alcohol weren't so wonderful and so i
stayed away from it and you know i
managed to get through uh college and
law school without drinking
when you think of the social pressures
in those scenarios and then later in
your professional career how did you
handle uh the fact that maybe you might
be the only person not drinking and then
you know does that extrapolate out to
other areas where there was social
pressure that you said hey you know i'm
just gonna do things my own way
well when i was in college um you know
obviously drinking is a big thing in
college i went to duke but i didn't have
enough money to join a fraternity where
a lot of the drinking occurred so i
tended to focus more on you know my
academic things and that drinking didn't
seem to help there and i wasn't probably
the most social figure at duke i doubted
most people probably knew i was even in
the class when i became chairman of the
board i suspect most people in my class
didn't even know i was in the class
because i was a relatively quiet you
know library kind of person so i wasn't
really the life of the party
um but you know it didn't it didn't hurt
me that much um i would say alcohol has
some real challenges people um some
people know how to drink some people
don't know how to drink but there's
always a worry that i had that maybe i
would have have an alcoholic gene and
maybe if i started drinking i would not
be out of stock yeah
and there's plenty of stories throughout
history of uh that being the case for
some people and it is an unfortunate
story but definitely one that uh that
people can go and read about um when you
think about this kind of
clear-headedness right so if you're not
drinking uh you've got this clear mind
you're able to kind of focus on the
things you think are most important talk
to me about some of the most influential
things that you've read you've read a
ton of books uh and obviously sometimes
it's for interviews other times it's
because out of personal interest what
are some of the things that you wish
that you had read earlier in your career
or for young people today you say hey
these are the two or three things that
you know i think could really help shape
your world view or set you up for
success
well i would say if my advice to people
and i give a commencement address is
really things like you can't read too
much
you just got to keep reading and not and
and basically show some intellectual
curiosity
um i think learning how to speak
publicly is also very useful uh life is
to some extent about persuading people
to do what you want
and your pal your parents your spouse
your children your partners or how do
you persuade people do what you want
well you do it by writing well like
thomas jefferson perhaps or you speak
well like martin luther king or abraham
lincoln or you lead by example which is
also a very good way to persuade people
george washington staying at valley
forge with his troops even though he
didn't have to you lead by example so i
tell people to practice communicating
try to avoid ethical mistakes
because it can ruin your reputation
forever and you never get your
reputation back i also tell people to
try to share the credit
don't always take the credit for
yourself and also take the blame if
something goes wrong be willing to take
the blame for it and own up to it um
those are some of the things i think
people should should learn how to do
and then what about influential books on
your life are there specific ones that
stand out
well i tend to read a lot of biographies
and so i'm always reading biographies
about people i think have done you know
wonderful things
i've read a lot of great biographies
about presidents united states and and
and obviously my era i was influenced by
books by about john kennedy
i went i worked early in my career for
ted sorensen who was john kennedy's
speechwriter and counsel and i read his
book on kennedy when i was young and i
read other books about president kennedy
when i was young by arthur schlesinger
and others and so i
i was influenced by a lot of those books
but in the end uh
what's important is reading actually
reading and finishing a book don't just
start it and then just drop it read it
through and then try to read as much as
you can and books are more important
than reading tweets i think because it
focuses your brain it teaches you how to
be disciplined to get through something
from start to finish and absorb the
information
when you talk to somebody like john who
was the speechwriter uh for kennedy tell
us a little bit in terms like what do
you learn from somebody like that
obviously that's somebody who has to
have a command of kind of current events
also has to understand the position of
the administration has to be able to
clearly communicate ideas but isn't
necessarily the one who's communicating
them themselves they're trying to help
somebody else communicate ideas what are
some things you learned
well you learn that you have to learn
how to get along with people you have to
take learn how to pick up signals people
sometimes don't tell you directly
exactly what they think but they do it
indirectly and so you gotta be good at
picking up signals uh learning how to
get along with people is a critical part
of success in life and that's true in
the white house or any part of the
government uh that you might be working
in because nobody in government is that
powerful they can't do anything by
themselves they need other people to do
it and that's true of course in the
business world as well but again um i
think young people
can't read too much they can't practice
speaking too much they can't practice
writing too much i am amazed at how many
people graduate from colleges that are
very good but when you ask them to write
something their their their writing
skills are relatively limited
it's because they've been writing too
many tweets they uh they're used to
using shorthand yeah so like fried
wonder if william shakespeare had lived
in the era of tweets would we have all
the shakespeare plays or would have been
diverted by having to to write tweets
all the time and not to actually finish
those plays
it's a a a fantastic question uh one of
the things that has become popular uh in
the discourse around uh uh kind of
building companies today is this idea of
work-life balance uh what was your daily
routine like when you first started
building carlisle and then what is it
today and how has that changed over time
well work-life balance i think is is
good i mean i would say i'm not the best
at it when i was young i was well known
for being a workaholic and working
around the clock there articles written
about that when i worked at the white
house at those times i i really wasn't
married i didn't have children and i
i didn't think i was uh talented enough
to do things so easily compared to some
other people so i had to put more time
in to make sure i was prepared and ready
to do what i had to do so i did i didn't
probably have a great work-life balance
early in my career later as i got
married had children you have to
obviously make some adjustments uh today
i still find that i'm i enjoy work and i
don't i'm doing nothing now that i think
is unpleasable i'm doing things that i
think is pleasurable and therefore i
don't regard his work but again
if you have a career and you don't enjoy
it that's work if you're doing something
you really love it's not work and
therefore i encourage people to
experiment and find something that they
really love doing so they don't regard
it as work as opposed to pleasure
when you think about that daily routine
today how do you decide what to do like
is it just
a it sounds like fun and i want to go
ahead and spend some time on it or do
you have some rubrics i try to balance
what i'm doing like carlyle what i'm
doing at declaration capital i have uh i
said i share seven non-profit boards and
they take time and then i want another
20 some non-profit boards where i'm not
the chair so i'm not as responsible and
then i have my philanthropic programs
and then i try to do a book a year or so
and then some tv things so i'm always
juggling things and trying to figure out
how to keep the schedule uh working
in given that so many entrepreneurs and
investors who are listening and watching
this they constantly are struggling with
that focus and that prioritization are
there things you've picked up over the
years on how to be better at that
well preparation is good uh jim baker
used to say that his father endured in
him prior preparation prevents poor
performance and i do try to prepare for
the interviews or i'm giving a speech or
whatever it might be try to prepare and
and give respect to the people you're
talking to so that's uh an important
lesson for me is actually try to be
prepared and know what you're doing
read as much as you can to get prepared
i think that's
important as well but in the end
practice is very important so i'm much
better at giving a speech today than i
was 25 years ago because i practice a
lot and i now know how to do it better
than i did but i encourage younger
people to try to practice giving
speeches practice doing interviews or
being interviewed
practice writing uh because in the end
these skills will come back to help you
one of the themes i think through our
conversation today that that's
fascinating is uh there are so many
podcasts there are so many tweets there
are so much of this content being
created uh but it's very different right
speaking on a podcast is very different
than giving a speech for 25 30 minutes
uh writing a tweet is very different
than sitting down and writing a book or
writing uh a memo an essay uh
i i do wonder how much of uh confusion
is going on between confusing uh kind of
motion with actual progress and trying
to get better at these skills uh and i
wonder if you've seen even inside of uh
some of your organizations where young
people are uh assigning you know value
to things that are motion but they may
not actually be progressing uh in the
way that you think they should be
it's hard to know i mean i think
sometimes younger people spend time on
things they think are going to be
valuable they may not be that valuable
you know i i do question how much you
know value is in in sending writing
tweets all the time or or responding to
tweets or reading all these tweets but
look uh some of the famous people have
200 300 million twitter followers i mean
it's just astounding that that many
people are following you know one or one
uh you know show business personality
but you know obviously
each to his own it's not for me yeah one
of the uh things about twitter that
absolutely cracks me up is uh you have
elon musk the world's richest man
obviously a fantastic entrepreneur who's
built a number of these very large
businesses and he was asked by i think
it was bloomberg at one point they said
would you rather be a billionaire or a
meme lord and uh what cracked me up is
like it's easier once he's a billionaire
to say no i'd rather just do memes on
the internet uh but it does feel like
there is some uh social uh change that
has occurred where people are using
obviously twitter and the tweets but
just memes and other ways of
communicating that it just seemed very
different than even 20 or 30 years ago
sure the older generation is always um
the last to catch on to things like uh
memes or or tweets and so forth so you
have to look the younger people about
how to communicate in the end uh life is
to some extent about communicating with
other people you can't do anything
pretty much by yourself you know how
many things can you actually do without
involving other people you have to
communicate and the best ways to
communicate always change though
learning how to talk is probably the
best way to really communicate in some
circles obviously some people though may
not have the ability to do that but
learning how to write or other ways
communicate with people i think is a
skill set that is really important yeah
the last thing that i wanted to ask you
about uh is the importance of critical
thinking in the process of critical
thinking it feels like we live in a
society today
where there's a lack of critical
thinking and critical thinking doesn't
necessarily assume that there's only one
outcome in that critical thinking
process but it's just the process of
sitting down and thinking more deeply
about decisions you may make or things
going on in the world are there certain
things that you've done in your life to
get better at that critical thinking
process uh or things that people can
take away to become better
well i think um
thinking is an important part of life
which sometimes gets lost in the
urge to um have an instant response to
everything or to have a tweet on
everything you know sometimes sitting
around with people having a serious
conversation or actually thinking on
yourself read something thinking about
it is very helpful and and practicing
out arguments that you try out on other
people when you're in your college dorm
rooms you're always arguing with people
it seems that you know in college dorms
and and practicing how to think and to
persuade people to do something i think
is a useful
useful skill and i encourage people to
young people particularly to learn how
to make their arguments much more
precise and clear about what they really
believe in
you mentioned at towards the beginning
of the conversation there's a lot of
people you know who are wealthy but
they're unhappy and then there's a lot
of people you know that are happy uh but
might not necessarily have money how do
you define happiness and how do you
evaluate whether you yourself are happy
well thomas jefferson famously wrote
about the pursuit of happiness in the
declaration of penance but in the
subsequent 50 years he lived he never
actually defined happiness or told
people how to get it and happiness is
the most elusive thing in life uh some
people are happy as you know you no
doubt know people that are happy with
their lives even though they might not
be famous or wealthy and there are a lot
of famous and wealthy people that are
tortured souls um it's just it's hard to
know how you get happiness if i knew how
to get happiness for everybody i would
give the secret it's not easy but i
think finding something that you feel is
doing is useful with your life is one of
the best ways to get there and i think
people are generally happier when they
are helping other people as opposed to
just aggregating their material assets
david i've really enjoyed our
conversation today you've wrote uh many
many books that i think people have
learned a ton from you've got a brand
new one that's coming out or is already
out how to invest
that book uh is full of interviews with
a bunch of very successful entrepreneurs
and also the stories of how they built
their wealth where can we send folks to
check out the book or to find you on the
internet
well i think it's so you can order it
from amazon and that's in
all the bookstores um it's publication
data september 13th and um you know i
think people will enjoy it because it
tells you the insights that the best
investors in in the united states have
had over the years and how they
developed their investment expertise so
i'd like to thank you for giving me this
much time to talk about it and other
subjects that i uh you and i share
mutually uh an interest in i appreciate
you uh you spend the time as well and uh
all of your other books have been
fantastic so i'm going to go out on the
limb and say that this one will be just
as good
as the past ones all right thanks a lot
i appreciate it all right bye bye